but like any couple we fight we got into
it last week she's like I'm gonna level
with you I need more compliments I was
like gosh so I took her to a
construction site
oh it gets confusing though because we
were walking around layering a homeless
guy cat called her he's like nice ass
baby I was like there you go huh she's
like what the hell are you gonna do
about that guy I'm like I'm gonna go
over there and give that guy a couple of
bucks she was like I don't want a cop
remember him I want to come from you I'm
like what a cotton that's a comment
she's like no no I'm gonna take you to a
gay bar see how you like it we go to a
gay bar these guys are all over me she's
like what do you think about that I was
like I [__] love it so now the new
fight is I bought a vintage car she
hates this car because I think you like
the car more than you like me it's like
what not that I like him more just
easier to understand I mean let's be
honest ladies you guys be very vague and
secretive car's pretty cut and dry out
of gas empty overheated hot there's no
games with the car the engine of a car
is never caught on fire in the dashboard
says I'm fine